REPORT.
WE WILL KEEP OUR EYES ON IT AND
KEEP US IN TOUCH THROUGHOUT THE
HOUR.
NOW SOCIAL DISTANCING FROM
REALITY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"THE ANGLE"."
THE LEFT RULES, HAVE YOU NOTICED
THIS?
IT NEVER SEEMS TO APPLY TO THEM.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS WITH
GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHUP NOT
WEARING HIS MASK OR
GOVERNOR WHITMER’S HUSBAND
TRAVELING TO THE FAMILY CABIN UP
NOR OR ESCAPING FROM ILLINOIS TO
THAT AWFUL DANGEROUS STATE OF
FLORIDA.
MAYOR THOUGHT HER HAIR STYLED AS
SHE KEPT US ALONG CLOSE FOR
EVERYONE ELSE SINCE CHICAGO.
BUT IF YOU STILL WANT TO GIVE
THESE GOVERNORS AND MAYORS THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT ON THESE
COVID LOCKDOWNS, NOW YOU CAN
DISABUSE YOURSELF OF THAT NOTION
FOR GOOD.
IN LATE APRIL, MAYOR de BLASIO
DENOUNCED THE WHO GATHERED FOR A
FUNERAL IN BROOKLYN AND HE USED
THE POLICE TO BREAK IT UP.
>> THE NOTION THAT PEOPLE WILL
GATHER IN LARGE NUMBERS AND TO
SPREAD A DISEASE THAT WILL KILL
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
IS UNACCEPTABLE TO ME.
IF YOU SAW ANGERED AND
FRUSTRATION, YOU ARE RIGHT.
I SPOKE OUT OF REAL DISTRESS
THAT PEOPLE’S LIVES WERE IN
DANGER BEFORE MY EYES.
AND I WILL NOT TOLERATE IT.
>> Laura: PEOPLE’S LIVES WERE
IN DANGER AT THE FUNERAL, OKAY.
BUT WHEN THRONGS OF LOOTERS
RULED THE STREET TO SMASH AND
GRAB AND PUSH ASIDE OR WORSE,
ANYONE IN THEIR WAY, SUDDENLY
THERE IS ZERO CONCERN FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH, COVID, AND THE POLICE
BY de BLASIO WITH A LIGHT
TOUCH.
>> OVERWHELMINGLY PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
PROTESTERS RESPECTING THE GROUND
RULES SET BY THE POLICE.
THE POLICE DOING EXACTLY WHAT
THEY ARE SO GOOD OUT.
>> THERE IS A SMALL ANARCHIST
GROUP THAT HAS BEEN VIOLENT, AND
THEN THERE IS A SMALL CRIMINAL
ELEMENT THAT HAS BEEN VIOLENT.
BUT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
PERCENTAGE COMPARED TO THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE
PROTESTERS AND THE PEOPLE.
>> Laura: NO COVID CONCERNS.
BUT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SHOW UP,
LET’S SAY LET’S MOVE ON TO
CHARLOTTE, NORTH CAROLINA, TO
MARCH AGAINST POLICE BRUTALITY,
OKAY THEY ARE WELCOME, FINE.
SO YOU ARE RIGHT POOL TO
PEACEFULLY PROTEST.
BUT IF THOUSANDS ARE AT A RALLY
IN CHARLOTTE, TWO MONTHS FROM
NOW, THEY ARE COLD THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE, DANGEROUS, SELFISH.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS EXTREMELY
IRRESPONSIBLE AND POTENTIALLY A
DEADLY THREAT TODAY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC.
TO MOVE THE REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
CONVENTION TO CHARLOTTE, HE
WANTS 20 MORE THOUSAND PEOPLE TO
GATHER IN THE ARENA THERE
PACKED, SCREAMING, SHOUTING ON
TOP OF HIS EACH OTHER IN THE
MIDST OF THIS PANDEMIC?
IS THAT WHAT HE IS SAYING?
>> Laura: HAVE ANY OF YOU SEEN
THE CROWDS IN RALEIGH AND
CHARLOTTESVILLE NORTH CAROLINA?
IF YOU WANT TO OPEN YOUR DOORS
TO CUSTOMERS, THEY WILL STOP YOU
OR SEND STATE INSPECTORS AND
THEY WILL HAVE MEASURING TAPES
AND MAKE SURE YOUR SALAD BAR IS
IN ORDER, BUT IF YOU WANT TO
RANSACK A RESTAURANT, THEY WILL
GIVE YOU THE GREEN LIGHT.
IF YOU WANT TO GO TO CHURCH,
THEY WILL SEND COPS OUT TO
HARASS YOU.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO BURN DOWN THE
CHURCH, THEY WILL BASICALLY LOOK
THE OTHER WAY OR EXCUSE IT.
IF YOU WANT TO PROTEST THE
LOCKDOWNS AT THE STATE CAPITAL,
YOU ARE CALLED A TERRORIST AND A
THREAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
BUT NOW IF YOU ARE MARCHING IN A
CROWD CARRYING A SIGN THAT SAYS
F TRUMP, YOU ARE ORGANIZING FOR
CHANGE, NO COVID PROBLEMS THEY
ARE.
AND IF YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
HITTING THE BEACH --
>> THIS VIRUS DOES NOT TAKE THE
WEEKENDS OFF.
THIS VIRUS DOESN’T GO HOME
BECAUSE IT IS A BEAUTIFUL, SUNNY
DAY AROUND OUR COAST.
>> Laura: BUT APPARENTLY THE
VIRUS HAS TAKEN THE ENTIRE WEEK
OFF.
OR OVERALL TOGETHER AND THEY
DIDN’T BOTHER TELLING US.
LOCKDOWNS AND RULES WERE GOOD
WHEN IT MADE YOUR LIVES AND
CONVENIENT AND TOOK THINGS THAT
WERE ESSENTIALLY VIEWED.
BUT ESSENTIALLY WHEN THE
LOCKDOWN INTERFERE -- INTERFERED
WITH ACHIEVING THEIR POLITICAL
GOALS, IT NO LONGER MATTERED.
SO MUCH SO MUCH FOR PHASE ONE,
23, FOUR.
THIS IS ALL POLITICAL FOR THE
DEMOCRATS FROM ALL OF IT.
THEY WANT TO STOP
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS FROM HAVING RALLIES
OR EVEN A CONVENTION.
MEANWHILE, THEY FLED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE PACKED
TIGHTLY OF THE STREETS AND PARKS
TO SUPPORT THEIR OWN EFFORTS TO
DEFEAT HIM.
ISN’T THAT A NEAT TRICK.
WHAT ABOUT THESE PROTESTS,
PEACEFUL PROTESTS NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT?
IT IS THE HALLMARK OF ANY FREE
SOCIETY.
WE APPLAUD PEOPLE’S PROTESTS.
AS WE EXPLAINED FOR MONTHS THE
LEFT-WINGERS TRIED TO FORCE US
TO STAY HOME.
BUT THE LEFT, THERE PROTEST HAD
BECOME ESSENTIALLY RIGHT NOW
PART OF A RELIGION THAT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT MUST BE
PREDICTED.
BUT IT’S ALSO BECOME PART SOCIAL
CLUB.
AND THE SAME GENIUSES WHO LOVE
TO MOCK BAPTISTS ARE OUT IN THE
STREET WITH THEIR OWN RITUALS.
MEMBERSHIP RULES, THEY HAVE
PUNISHMENT FOR HERETICS EVEN.
AND IT EVEN LOOK LIKE JONESTOWN
MEETS PILATES.
A BUNCH OF RICH, WHITE LIBERALS
GATHERED IN BETHESDA, MARYLAND A
SUBURB OF WASHINGTON, D.C., TO
REPEAT THEIR ALMOST RELIGIOUS
MANTRAS.
>> ABOUT RACISM, OR VIOLENCE.
I WILL USE MY VOICE AND THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE.
>> I WILL USE MY VOICE AND THE
MOST WAY POSSIBLE.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING IN MY POWER
TO TO TAKE CARE OF MY COMMUNITY.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Laura: NOW LET’S BE CLEAR,
EVERYONE IS INFURIATED.
ANYONE WITH A SHRED OF DECENCY
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO GEORGE
FLOYD.
EVERYONE WANTS JUSTICE TO BE
DONE.
BUT THOSE CREEPY RALLIES HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH GEORGE FLOYD.
AT LEAST FOR MOST OF THE PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT.
HIS TRAGEDY IS THEY ARE EXCUSE.
THE FOLKS YOU SEE YELLING AT
COPS ON TV COME A LOT OF THE
WEALTHY SUBURBAN KIDS.
I GUESS THEY ARE TIRED SITTING
HOME PLAYING VIDEO GAMES.
THEY ARE BUYING STUFF ON AMAZON
PRIME.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CHECK THEIR
PROLIFIC FILMIC PRIVILEGE WHILE
CHECKING THEIR APPLE WATCHES.
SO LET’S WATCH EVERYONE ON THEIR
KNEES.
NOT IN PRAYER FOR RACIAL HEARING
FOR GEORGE FLOYD, BUT IN
SUBMISSION TO THEIR EVER-GROWING
LIST OF DEMANDS.
TODAY, THEY DEMAND WE DEFINED
THE POLICE.
>> MOST PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE
THAT ONLY 5% OF THE ARRESTS
HAPPEN IN THE COUNTRY ACTUALLY
HAPPEN FOR A VIOLENT CRIME.
WE DON’T NEED THE POLICE AND THE
WAY WE DO.
IN THE POLICING APPARATUS
ALWAYS.
>> TOMORROW THEY MAY DEMANDS
ABOLISHING PRISONS ALTOGETHER
EXCEPT FOR THE PEOPLE THEY DON’T
LIKE.
LIBERALS USE TO CELEBRATE THE
END RESULT AND I REMEMBER THAT,
THEY ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE YOUR
OWN TRUE SELF.
FREE EXPRESSION WAS CELEBRATED,
BUT NOW IT IS REALLY BIZARRE
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL ABOUT
ENFORCING THEIR OWN ORTHODOXY,
THEIR OWN CONFORMITY IN SPEECH
AND BELIEF.
YOU DEVIATE FROM THEIR
EVER-CHANGING MOVING GOALPOST
AND THEY WILL EXCOMMUNICATE YOU
AT ONCE.
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST AND
DEBATE.
WHO CAN BLAME THEM.
THEY CAN’T DEFEND THEIR LOUSY
IDEAS OR HATRED OF AMERICA.
AND THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO
MAKE ANYONE’S LIFE BETTER,
REALLY BETTER.
AND SO THAT DISTRACTS YOU WITH
THE LATEST TWO MINUTE SYMBOL OR
HATE OR MAY BE SOME A CAPPELLA
SINGING ON YOUTUBE TO MAKE
EVERYBODY FEEL GOOD AT THE
MOMENT, BUT IN THE END IT
DOESN’T MAKE ANYBODY’S LIFE
BETTER.
IT CERTAINLY DOES NOT PUT MONEY
IN YOUR POCKET.
TODAY THEY ARE TRYING TO KEEP US
TRAPPED IN A NEVER ENDING CYCLE
OF MEANINGLESS AND PROTEST
SOPHIE’S.
IT’S LIKE EATING JUNK FOOD.
IT TASTES GOOD AT THE MOMENT,
BUT IT WILL NOT MAKE YOU
STRONGER.
IF WE HAD AN HONEST MEDIA, THEY
WOULD DO MORE THAN REACTING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TWEET OR WALK
ACROSS THE PARK TO ST. JOHN’S
CHURCH.
THEY WOULD BE ASKING TOUGH
QUESTIONS LIKE THIS.
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN, IF YOU ARE
SUCH A CHAMPION FOR MINORITIES,
WHY DO OPPOSE EDUCATIONAL CHOICE
FOR DISADVANTAGED FAMILIES AND
SCHOOLS?
AND IF YOU KNEW, MR. BIDEN, HOW
TO HEAL A RACIAL DIVIDE, WHY
DIDN’T YOU AND PRESIDENT OBAMA
DO IT EIGHT YEARS WHILE YOU WERE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE?
WHY DIDN’T YOU FIGHT AGAINST
THOSE JOBS BEING SHIPPED TO
CHINA?
WHY DID IT TAKE PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO PASS CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM?
FORTUNATELY THE WHOLE WORLD HAS
NOT YET BECOME A GIANT STUDENT
CENTER.
THERE ARE STILL GROWN-UP PEOPLE
WITH REAL MONEY MAKING REAL BETS
ON THE FUTURE.
AND THOSE PEOPLE, THE INVESTORS
WHO DRIVE OUR MARKETS, THEY SEE
A VERY DIFFERENT WORLD FROM THAT
SIGNED BY ENGLISH MEASURES WHO
KNOW MORE ABOUT POKEMON THAN THE
FOUNDERS OF THE COUNTRY.
AND INVESTORS NEED TO SEEM TO BE
OPTIMISTIC WHO WILL WIN THE
BATTLE OF IDEAS AND EVEN AFTER
PANDEMIC AND UNREST, THEY ARE
BETTING ON AMERICA.
THE DOW SHOT OVER 26,000 TODAY,
STUNNING.
WE ARE COMING BACK.
AND THAT MEANS MORE JOBS FOR
AMERICANS OF ALL RACES AND CREED
CREED.
AND WHO WOULD WANT TO PROTEST
AGAINST THAT?
AND THAT IS "THE ANGLE."
SPEAKING OF TWISTING THE DATA,
THE LEFT IS DOING JUST THAT TO
FUEL THEIR NARRATIVE THAT THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE
INHERENTLY SYSTEMICALLY RACIST.
SO WHAT ARE THE NUMBERS THAT
ACTUALLY TELL US?
ACCORDING TO "WASHINGTON POST"
DATABASE THAT TRACKED THESE
NUMBERS, POLICE OFFICERS FATALLY
SHOT 1,004 PEOPLE, 1,004 PEOPLE
IN 2019, OF THOSE ONLY 41 WERE
UNARMED.
IF YOU WRITE THOSE NUMBERS DOWN
AMONG RATES, YOU FIND 20 UNARMED
WERE WHITE, AND TEN WERE
BLACK.
AS LONG AS WE ARE LOOKING AT